well I I think too like uh y'all really
never really went nowhere it's just
people were doing the sound like you
know what I think of like some some
records like people been sampling or
doing the not even sampling just doing
y'all style for so long and getting
credit for it you know what I'm
saying and then I think people forget
like hey Megan's from Texas Travis from
Texas you know post
Malone you know have you met po post yet
through the following year oh nice yeah
you know I met who Morgan wallan how was
that he's fire it was a
time it was a time what's it like
hanging with him what y'all
do I was uh he came to one of my shows
oh he did so he was he's just [__]
with you yeah yeah cuz he's tapped in on
the hip-hop [__] for people who don't
know Texas really did it for
me had that took me Every Which Way but
yeah he pulled up to one of the shows he
was a dug hunting in where was we at
Arkansas was we at
Arkansas so we popped up to one of the
shows we got drunk I got [__] up yeah
he was already [__] up right but then
I popped open at 42 M it took us to a
whole another level any Edibles
involved uh no a here yeah but no not
there no
that was good y got y y'all got y'all
got lit and uh and had a good time so
like he's like the biggest country
[__] star of the last I don't know
how many years the Drake of country he's
the Drake of country so would you guys
work together we actually cooking some
up man really yeah that's crazy so I got
something I got something coming with
Morgan Wallen I got something coming
with post
Malone I got something coming with
Morgan wall and post Malone
check you out man I just hope you know
uh you don't forget about the little
people I'm the
little in this situ not quite literally
yeah well amongst those three you
wouldn't be the little
guy I mean how tall is po
Malone he like six I think he like six
we're about the same height yeah he's
about 6 feet yeah I thought he was tall
never seen him in person so he's cool
for sure yeah you should tell him how
you're a Houston Texans fan though he he
knows that I almost lost I almost lost
the feature off of that yeah is there
shouldn't be a rivalry different [__]
conferences one team's brand new I just
feel like we should just Embrace each
other like especially after we win the
Super Bowl the Texans are like Teslas
and like the Cowboys are like uh for
Pinto that's [__] up that's real
[__]
up okay maybe not a pinto okay I ate two
of them you got to eat two you know what
the C the Cowboys are like n like a 2010
Camaro that your homie who still sells
weed is driving and he you know he's
driving it like it's still 2010 you know
what I'm saying like he got some rims on
it but the r hey hey hey he got a little
he got three three good rims and a dut
on the back right and all the rims are
scratched cuz he can't park that's the
Cowboys that's [__] up yeah hey can
one of y'all hear me another one in the
waters I'm promoting the brand hey this
can hard who is your team don't no
no I'm a I'm an Arizona Cardinals Fan so
I actually know what it's like to be a
in the depths of Hell on the football
fandom sir I got a Texas boy over there
though Kyler Murray yeah he should come
home to the Cowboys so you that that
would be crazy do you want to get rid of
Dak I mean d be bullshitting in the
playoffs yeah it's the hips y have you
guys met CD lamb yet we've seen all of
them at the
clue you cuz you don't care I would DJ
and the Cardinals would be there the
night before a big game at my club do
you know how [__] pissed I'd be cuz
I'd be like y got a game tomorrow bro
there's a [__] game tomorrow and you
know what's crazy that's I heard there
was a couple players at the at the club
uh this past game right before and
that's what happened cuz they be in
there loose I didn't seen D with his
shirt but
D went crazy Dak shirtless in the club D
went crazy oh yeah that that sound that
sounds about
right we seen Jamal Adams in there
too yeah we don't see no he from he I
think he from
Carolton he went to school in Carolton
but yeah see jayen what Jaylen rer rer
wait wait wait wait no no he was the guy
who was on the Eagles mhm I was thinking
rugs the guy who got into that accident
on the radar
oh yeah that was rough rip to those
folks um all right so uh has there been
anything uh for you that you've noticed
like because things are getting bigger
for you right like are you are you
becoming is like hard for you to like go
like whatever City you're in go to the
store go to the mall like uh like out of
state no it's you know I you got your
couple people here and there but in
Texas it's over for you yeah I can't go
into Walmart without taking like 30
pictures that's crazy you're still going
to Walmart huh yeah well I mean when I'm
at home at home no we just order it and
N pick it up yeah Walmart's a wild place
in Texas yeah people who don't know man
[__] Southern Walmart's bro something
different
world you ever back in the day when they
were 24 hours you remember that yeah
stopped they stopped during the pandemic
they stopped that's what I'm saying like
when I was a kid we used to just get
[__] bored and just [__] kick
Walmart my granny's so mad that's when
she do her her best shopping yeah people
will be thinking like oh I could get
some shopping done but then there's some
stupid ignorant High drunk [__]
in there riding around in the [__]
handicap
scooters my granny always thought that
that's when the um the freshest products
was out and then I [__] be in there
on a bike you know what I'm saying you
go to the bike section get on that
[__] bike don't let them have
one of them big ass baskets full of
basketballs in the middle of the [__]
toy area you turn it into the [__]
get goddamn ass off the yeah shout
toet Donuts sh Donuts to eat now get a
whole meal and water oh yeah that's if
you there before six though you said
chicken and donuts simultaneously what
you're talking about rotisserie the
slurping machine was just right you ever
had Ranch Wings Ranch Wings I've had
wings
no missing it you got to come kick it
with us for a day hey man that's try I I
go to Walmart you know every every now
and again I've graduated in life to be a
Target guy you know we going go to
Target high as [__] tet on the beat and
it's harder to it's harder I'll be in
Walmart like
[__] harder for what I don't know their
cameras is just extremely harder to
steal yeah yeah yeah man yeah Walmart
they don't care but you know what though
what Walmart does have if you're trying
to if you're trying to steal Walmart has
the guy checking your receipt at the
door
have that that [__] do not work but but
they have a guy they have like a line of
defense there as we target you just walk
out now what if I know him oh the the
receipt guy or you just what if I know
the receipt guy what if I what what if
when I walk in I say hey I got a $100
for you if you let me you know what I'm
saying I used to steal uh sports cards
and magazines and what else did I steal
from Walmart back in the day I don't
know if I go to Walmart and I get 15
items seven of them items I'm not paying
for self
checkout oh yeah we had this discussion
got it's your employee discount cuz
you're an employee at that point you're
doing their job you feel definitely hey
definitely more you walk up with that
receipt as long as you got a receipt
they don't
care yeah back in the day we used to go
to the mall and [__]
throw baggy pants are popping youed
should be able to throw like two pairs
of pants on under your regular jeans and
go sell them like [__] expensive ass
jeans so like Lucky jeans or whatever
the
[__] little shoplifter never hurt nobody
I steal sometimes I'll steal now bro I
be hey don't let me be standing in line
at a gas station on a road trip it's him
I'm like listen him he's the the worst
influence cuz it don't matter how much
money he got he's forever going to take
something out he not paying for nothing
out the gas station so you steal
everything out the gas station who I
ain't stole a day in my life okay so you
borrow
stuff I
borrow you'll be in the middle of
nowhere on a road trip and you guys
probably on tour you get out there's
[__] two ladies working maybe one
lady working you got I don't care how
many people the easiest [__] is you're
looking at some [__] and you're like man
I don't care how many people working
I'll just buy water and and put you know
put 50 on pump 12 and cuz we already
know he'll be using us as decoys cuz
he'll do some [__] like like he'll stand
right behind us while we paying and then
when we walk out he just walk out with
us or while I done paid and I'm sitting
here waiting on somebody he just toss
the [__] in my bed you ever put anything
under the cart during self checkout that
way you can kind of say like I forgot
that was under there like you might be
pushing like I always put some [__] like
I like I never pay for my pack of water
I'm a fake skin I can like you think
it's scaming no no I [__] make the noise
beep I don't pay for water I just always
just I don't remind them that it's on
the bottom of my [__]
cart